the Clark County Corridor ruling a man's
death a homicide due to the actions of
Henderson Police now this determination
that police's use of force killed
53-year-old Ronald Winborn comes nearly
two months after it happened on March
21st we are told winborne lived for
about six days before dying in jail he
had been booked on assault and resisting
arrest charges for allegedly threatening
police with a knife we've received no
information from Henderson Police about
why they did not tell us about this
death Henderson Police calling it an
open investigation have not said if any
officers are facing any charges